your grace everyone you know will die
before winters over if we don't defeat
the enemy to the north as far as I can
see you are the enemy to the north I'm
not your enemy
the dead are the enemy the dead what's
up ladies and gentlemen welcome back for
my Game of Thrones Season eight episode
1 plot leek breakdown video now that I
have read the entire plot leaked I want
to start giving my thoughts on each
episode I don't know how many of you
were subscribed to my channel last
season but I plan on breaking down the
plot League just like I did with season
7s as soon as the season 7 plot leaked
it the Internet I made my first video
where I just read everything that the
league said then I made breakdown videos
for each episode where I went scene by
scene and just gave some of my thoughts
when I did those videos I invited a dawn
of Ice and Fire on my channel last year
to go over the plot leak with me but
this year I'm just gonna do it by myself
I had plans of bringing someone else on
here to give another perspective on
these things but I just don't have the
time to wait and hope my schedule aligns
with someone else's I kind of need to
get these done soon that way I can move
on to other content I want to get back
to predictions and theories so hopefully
I can finish these videos by the end of
the weekend I do want to say something
before I begin most of the things I'm
gonna say in these videos will be based
on my opinions and speculation we
haven't had a whole bunch of evidence
from the filming locations this year
only so many photos and videos have
leaked so we still don't know too much
about how season 8 will unfold it will
be kind of tricky trying to discredit
certain things in this leak because no
one knows what all will happen next
season but I will try to use what
evidence I have so far from what
spoilers have come out already I won't
spend too much time trying to pick apart
all the dialogue in this league because
it's not like someone has a tape
recorder on the set for us to know what
will or won't be said I have no idea
what the characters will say to each
other next season so most of the
dialogue in the leak could be right for
all I know
but if it sounds too stupid or out of
place then of course I will say
something about that so without further
ado let's get started season 8 episode 1
began with barrack and torment arriving
at Castle black to warn everyone there
about what happened at
eastwatch-by-the-sea when barrack and
tormund got the castle black barrack
tells torment to go south while barrack
stays with Lord Commander and basically
as soon as tormund leaves the army of
the dead show up in attack Castle black
while the night king and the rest of his
army head for the last hearth this first
scene raised a few red flags for me
right away because according to other
reports the first scene will not take
place at Castle black I made a video
about a month ago and it was based on a
report that came out that said the first
scene will be in winter town which is
right outside of Winterfell if that
report is true then it pretty much
discredits the entire leak but it
doesn't mean some of these things won't
happen still I do think it makes sense
for torment in barrack to go to Castle
black next as we all know barrack and
torment were standing on top of the wall
when it was attacked the night King
brought down a big portion of the wall
that was connected to
eastwatch-by-the-sea and when the wall
came down it tore down all the stairs
that led to the ground so barrack and
torment might not be able to climb down
the wall at Eastwatch anymore now that
the staircase is gone I don't think
there was an elevator system there
either and even if there was it would
have fell with the wall anyway I think
barrack and torment will need to walk
along the top of the wall until they get
to a castle that has something in place
for them to get down since most of the
castles have been out of commission for
a very long time they might not be able
to get down until they get to Castle
black if they are stuck up there until
then their first scene should be at
Castle black but it might not be the
first scene of the show because as I
said the first scene should be at winter
town near Winterfell I also don't think
it makes much sense for the night king
to have any of his army go to Castle
black first there are only a few dozen
men at Castle black so it's a very small
target and it's completely out of the
night King's way of heading further
south now obviously we don't know
exactly where the night King is heading
next but I don't think he cares about
Castle black now that he's already
through the wall I think he should be
moving to bigger targets in the north
instead
whirring about 40 men that is 150 miles
away from eastwatch-by-the-sea I think
barrack and tormund will go to Castle
black simply because they have no other
way of getting down unless a closer
castle has stairs or an elevator safe
enough to use still but I don't think
Castle black will be attacked right away
and I don't think this will be the first
scene anyway
I believe the report that said it will
be a winter town so with that being said
I think this farce scene is incorrect
the next scene says bran is in the
godswood and he asks the maester how
long he has been in his vision the
maester said a few hours but brain
doesn't remember seeing anything so he
thinks something is wrong I really don't
have much to say about this there is no
way to know if this will happen or not
right now I find it strange that bran
would have been at the weirwood tree for
hours but he hasn't seen anything Bryan
has usually always been able to see
something when he tries but who knows
maybe the night King is able to affect
his visions even more now that he
doesn't have the wall blocking him I
don't think they scene will happen like
this but just because I don't agree with
it doesn't mean it's false the next
scene is where Daenerys John and
everyone else arrives at Winterfell is
gate this is when Sansa is looking at
Daenerys suspiciously interior notices
they are reinforcing the walls this
scene doesn't sound too crazy because as
we all know John and Daenerys are going
to Winterfell and I'm sure people will
be looking at her suspiciously or
cautiously everyone did tell John not to
go greet with her but he went anyway and
now he's bringing her and her dragons to
Winterfell so I'm sure there will be
some tension when they arrive I think we
can all pretty much agree to that it
also makes sense that Winterfell was
reinforcing their walls we have already
seen tons of photo evidence that proves
they are doing this Brian saw the night
King bring down the wall because he sent
the Ravens to Eastwatch to spy on the
night king's army this is also the same
scene where John and Arya are reunited
John and Arya hug and John says so you
did stick them with the pointy end
personally I thought that was kind of a
corny thing to say but I have no idea
what John will say to arya when he sees
her again i am hoping the reunion is a
little bit more emotional than this i
would prefer if they were able to meet
again
so they can focus on their reunion even
more but once again just because I don't
want it to happen this way doesn't mean
it won't
the reunion could happen like this but I
hope not
after this they all go into the hall and
John tells everyone that he's now
serving Daenerys Targaryen this makes
everyone angry in Sansa is shocked now
we know songs are already knows John did
this because she said that to
Littlefinger so it doesn't make much
sense that Sansa would be shocked when
hearing this unless she is shocked
because he said this in front of all the
other Lords but they would have to find
out how their relationship is working
sometime anyway if John does say this in
front of every northern Lord I bet it
will cause some problems we know they do
not like Targaryen and they were already
mad that John was going south to meet
Daenerys anyway so if he comes back
saying he bent the knee to her I could
see things getting ugly because of it
Lord Royce Glover and probably even
Lyanna Mormont may have a few choice
words for John when and if he announces
this so this doesn't sound too crazy
either
it also says John will try to calm
everyone down by explaining how much
Daenerys has helped him already she
brought her armies dragons and even
sacrificed a dragon by saving him north
of the wall if tensions would rise and
people would start questioning why John
brought Daenerys to Winterfell he
probably would say some things like this
because they are true
it also says sam asks brain when he
plains on telling John the truth about
his parents and bran says not right now
because of the tensions being so high
obviously I don't know if it will happen
exactly like this but I expected this
revealed to be delayed we know the show
loves to draw these kind of things out
for as long as possible
I don't expect bran to tell John the
moment he sees him but I'm sure he will
try to tell him when they have a moment
alone the next scene was was Cersei and
Qyburn and this is when Qyburn takes
Cersei under the Red Keep and reveals a
bunch of wildfire underneath the city I
actually really like this scene
I have always suspected there was more
wild fire under King's Landing and we
all know that's one of Circe's best
weapons I don't think she will ever bend
the knee or hand over the city she
probably would try to go out Mad King
style if push comes to shove so I think
we could see
something like this next season I
wouldn't be surprised if Qyburn knew
where more wildfire was or at the very
least he might be working on making some
himself there might not be a scene where
Qyburn takes Cersei below the ground to
show her more wildfire but I bet they
will have some saved away for the end of
the season when King's Landing is
attacked
we know they have been building an
enormous set for King's Landing and some
of the set will be destroyed and burned
so we should see a great battle in the
city next season and hopefully there is
some wildfire involved the next scene
said your own arrives and Essos to pick
up the golden company I really don't
have any issue with this because we all
know you're on already left at the end
of season seven to go get them so he
should be arriving at the beginning of
the season I won't really go into the
dialogue in this scene either because
there is no way to know what you're on
and the commander of the golden company
will say to each other they might talk
about the dragons or they might not who
really knows there is also a scene that
says Jaime meets with bran outside of
the city and he tells him he's leaving
to go north if bran wants to get paid
and survived the winter he should come
and bran decides to go with him we know
that's where Jamie's going but we don't
know if he will get bran first or not I
would like to think he will Jamie will
definitely need the help and he won't
want to travel into enemy territory
alone broaden wouldn't have much of a
reason to stay in King's Landing once
Jamie leaves anyway
Jamie was the one that was seeing bran
was paid so he might want to stay close
to him to make sure he still gets what
is owed to him I think this scene does
make sense Jamie will probably find bran
before he gets too far away
unless Cersei would get to him first
bran and Cersei are not allowed to film
together but we all know there are ways
around that although Jamie and bran
leaving together does sound plausible
the next scene is what Jon and Daenerys
and the crypts of Winterfell they talk
about Jon's dead family members and that
leads into a quick conversation about
Leona and Rhaegar there is a very good
chance this scene could happen a report
came out a while ago that said they were
filming in the crypts and it said there
would be multiple scenes down there and
those scenes would take place in episode
one and two it also said some main
characters would be involved in those
scenes so it does line up with this leak
but
don't know which main characters will be
down there it could be John and Daenerys
and if they do they probably would talk
about John's family since this is where
the people come to pay their respects to
their fallen loved ones John and
Daenerys are both aware of the story
about Rhaegar and Lyanna so they could
talk about that too
especially since Rhaegar is Danny's
brother she probably would have
something to say on the matter and I
will not be surprised if we get it seen
what John and Daenerys down in the
crypts of Winterfell
but there is no way to know what they
will talk about if they go down there
after this it says Tyrion is seen alone
in a room writing a letter to someone
but it's not revealed who this letter
was - I'm really not too sure about this
one I obviously read the entire leak and
this scene was never referenced again
nor was there any mention of a letter in
the later episodes
I know plot leaks do leave several
details out in every episode but there
is no other evidence of this happening
so I don't know if this will happen
it probably won't since it does seem
like a plot hole right now this is also
when torment arrives at Winterfell is
gate and he seems distressed and he
tells John and Daenerys about the night
king and Viserion destroying
eastwatch-by-the-sea this really doesn't
make much sense to me either
brain saw the night king destroy the
wall so brain should have told everyone
what happened so they could warn
everyone and prepare for war as soon as
John and Daenerys arrived in Winterfell
they should be told about the xix coming
south with the dragon they shouldn't
have to wait for torment to arrive from
Castle black to tell everyone I don't
think it will play out like this I know
at the beginning of this leak Brian said
he doesn't remember seeing anything but
I find that hard to believe
unless bran is all of a sudden turning
into a bad guy and withholding
information it doesn't make sense for
him not to warn everyone immediately I
did love the last scene of this episode
it's when the last hearth is attacked
and everyone there is turned into whites
I made a video months ago saying I
believe this is what will happen I think
the night King will take out a few
castles right below the wall before he
gets to Winterfell this would be a great
way to build tension throughout the
season by having the Night king's army
get bigger and closer episode by episode
there was another report that said
little Ned number and Elise Karstark
wasn't
fast filming we know John was sending
them back to their castle so if we see
them again that means we should see them
at the car hold or the last horf most
likely getting attacked unless they were
able to flee back to Winterfell and
that's where we see them again but I
would prefer each episode to end with a
big cliffhanger by having the night King
take out a few targets to create even
more fear throughout the north and
mostly the Seven Kingdoms I haven't seen
any evidence that indicates this will
happen but since they brought the two
actors back again there is a good chance
something like this could go down I
would love for the episodes to end with
the tax from the night king but that's
just my opinion
let me know what you thought about
episode 1 do you think most of it makes
sense or not I don't think this episode
was too bad it's mostly just setting
things up for where we left off at the
end of season 7 so it would be kind of
hard to guess this one wrong but as you
can see there were a few things that I
thought sounded off there is enough
evidence and reports out there to let us
know some things that will happen but
not enough to confirm or deny everything
if you agree or disagree with any of my
points or opinions please put them down
below in the comment section I want to
thank all of you for watching the video
and I also want to thank everyone on
patreon that supports the channel have a
great day everyone I will see you very
soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you